George Clooney is like the gold standard
for class and dignity and he gets it he
once said my famous is my currency and
he uses that for causes that are
important to him I think Brad and
Angelina are pretty remarkable in the
way they manage their family their
public image to me Madonna is just
amazing and her ability to remain
relevant for a very long time you know I
look at celebrities having been in
Hollywood more than 20 years and
following it a lot of people are famous
for their moment but people who are
still relevant 20 years later to me that
that's pretty darn impressive I think a
lot of these corporate CEOs live in a
different world they live in a world of
multimillion-dollar bonuses they live in
a world of private jets and that's the
milieu they live in and I think the auto
companies got it they they had a misstep
they got it they drove back to
Washington the second time and look it
happened they got a deal out of it so I
think there's a lot of they require
people and people like me just because
somebody's the CEO of a company I need
to tell them the truth I need to say
you're not playing this right or this
isn't going to work right now for these
reasons and whether they choose to
listen or not I look at it as
responsibility of mine to deal in
reality because if I don't tell them and
they go out there going to say why
didn't you tell me if I do tell them and
they still choose to do it maybe they
listen next time there are people who
don't care about the rules I i used the
i used the example of former Vice
President Dick Cheney he he knows people
don't really like him out there his poll
numbers are down but he figures screw
you I was the vice president united
states i had all the power I wanted
and I'm beyond caring about what my
public image is and he's somebody who
transcended that we look at somebody
like Ann Coulter the political pundit
and she likes to be intentionally
provocative she likes to say words that
will upset and shocked people the n-word
in the F word and get the press and then
doesn't care because she believes that
all press is good press which is not
something I necessarily believe in fact
that's one of my core beliefs that no
not all press is good press but most
people who are in the public eye then
they have earned it maybe Yoko Ono's
tired of it after all these years but
again unless he does something pretty
significant or makes an appearance and
what you're not going to see about her
so people have to do a little something
to keep their interest going in their
image
you